madame monsieur bonsoir il n'était pas
le favori et c'est lui qui emporte le
trophée vincent riou est le héros du
jour ou plutôt de la nuit il vient de
franchir la ligne d'arrivée du vendée
globe et le public lui a bien sûr
réservé un triomphe benoît rousset 87
jours 10 heures 47 minutes et 55
secondes le chrono de tous les records
pour vincent riou ils bouclent peu avant
minuit son tour du monde en solitaire en
monocoque sans escale et sans assistance
sur un incroyable exploit premier pour
son premier vendée globe sur prb le
bateau du précédent vainqueur michel
desjoyeaux qui avait mis cinq jours de
plus que lui
vincent riou dit vincent le terrible a
été accueilli en héros aux sables
d'olonne sont à but est d'arriver
le navigateur étonnamment calme est
revenu sur son aventure hors du commun
mais trois mois que
24 heures sur 24 on se bagarre et c'est
vrai que c'est usant à la brède arrivé
comme ça en plus avec cet accueil là
c'est totalement magique un fait
ça reste un élément droits
extraordinaires et les boules de billard
aujourd'hui moi je finis cette course
avec la satisfaction du travail bien
fait c'est vraiment ça mon
c'est vraiment ça qui me fait plaisir
quoi il ya eu la bagarre du début à la
fin on s'est battu il a fallu rester
vraiment vigilance jusqu'à la dernière
minute je dirais même jusqu'à ce matin
où j'étais encore arrêtée dans les
petits airs avec jean le cam derrière et
voila quoi je pense c'est toujours
pareil les victoires aux bagarres le
plus sont forcément les plus belles et
les salaires c'était une belle bagarre
béarnais incroyable scénario dans cette
course pas comme les autres qui dès le
départ quand les allures de régates
les duels entre vincent riou et jean le
cam de marin au tempérament bien
différent plus avec mike golding auront
dominé ce cinquième vendée globe la
différence vincent riou la fera après le
passage du cap horn
grâce à de meilleures options météo le
suspense de ce final à 3 a donc pris fin
aujourd'hui
vincent riou peut savourer son éclatante
victoire dans le chenal des sables
d'olonne où des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont venues l'accueillir avec
ses proches
vincent riou on va pouvoir enfin
regarder derrière lui et attendre sans
crainte ses deux poursuivants attendus
eux dans les heures qui viennent